يعني انا تحول الي صار حصل لي ناس في جيلي
جيلي اول شيء الحكومه السعوديه الملك عبد
العزيز واستمرت بعد ذلك الى فتح المدارس
فتح المدارس
كانت مرحله مهمه جدا جدا بدات في
الخمسينات
والتوسع فيها ثانيا الاعتمام الاهتمام
بالصحه بالصحه العامه
زياره اطباء القرى الفقيره هذه وبعدين
تدرج الشيء بشكل تدريجي يعني لجميع
عشناها
الكثير من زملائي في الابتدائي لان لم
يستمر بسبب الغالب الحاجه الى
ذهبوا الى بعض المعاهد المعاهد المعلمين
لتعطيهم رواتب مجزئه وجيده ولكن نقله
ليه فيكم القران في نجد
ما عدا الرياض اللي كانوا يطور بشكل كبير
كانت نقله كبيره يعني ثوره لما اقول
الكوريسين كمثال يعني انا اتذكر امي تطبخ
الله يرحمها تطبخ عن طريق ايش عن طريق
الحطب
وبقايا الجمال هذا
وتجميع الحطب وانواعه والدخان والمشاكل
الصحيه المرتبطه في العمليه ما هي بسيطه
لما اجي تكون خلاص
تنظر الى المنازل تشوف دخان من كل بيت
توقف هذا كله وتوقف الحطب وتوقف هذا ثوره
ثوره مين بسيطه ابدا